[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci amis des césars
bonjour j'ai envie d'être charge suis
très content très content s'est
longtemps que j'attendais donc bon ben
on attend cerexhe peut pas tout lui
demander non plus c'est pas me garde du
corps un pas du tout alors vous allez
tout ça c'est pas du tout des vigiles ou
quoi que ce soit mes danseurs n'ont plus
loin alors c'est mon banquier mon
comptable un point vous êtes c'est a
priori un juste parce qu'ils sont jeunes
ils pourraient par année mais c'est
sympa ça croyante
non c'est mon bon ok mon comptable est
en fait il voulait voir des stars en
vrai donc voilà vous êtes contents vous
avez vu il y en a pas vous avez dit
aller